so Ryan Reynolds has two movies coming
out this weekend and one he plays some
men and Black Death Hunter guy that
reviews coming soon and this one he
plays a snail with super fast and
furious powers he really wants us to
forget about Green Lantern turbo is
about a snail voiced by Ryan Reynolds
and he dreams of being fast he watches
the Indy 500 he looks at the winners who
actually win the race and he listens to
their speeches and he just wants to be
like them he wants to be faster than all
of his other snails he goes to his job
every day which is essentially a
monitoring the tomato garden in the yard
and the house that he lives in he kind
of hangs out in the potted plans of this
person's house and during the day he
tries to run from a child on a little
bike who likes to crush snails and they
have to look out for birds that
sometimes come down and pick them off
one day he gets blown inside the engine
of a car in the middle of a street race
and gets injected with nitrous oxide and
becomes a super snail who can go faster
than any of the other snails and from
then on we get to see how he gets to
reach that dream of wanting to be fast
and wanting to be in the Indy 500 now
there are certain types of kids movies
there are some kids movies that you
think okay this is definitely a kids
movie to me that's like happy feet or
cars and then there are films for kids
that are actually for the entire family
to me that's like Toy Story or
Despicable Me for instance these are
films that the whole family can get
together and no one feels like they're
shortchanged everyone feels like they're
having a good time turbo for me was more
of a kid's film you know I wasn't hating
myself watching it I didn't want to die
or anything but it's definitely a film
that your children will appreciate or if
you are younger that you'll appreciate
more but it doesn't really have that
much for the adults to enjoy it is
definitely an OK film you can watch it
and not feel like you wasted any time
but in all respects it's very generic
and you've seen it before you can tell
where each plot point is gonna hit you
know where everything's gonna go and you
can pretty much predict where
everything's gonna happen and it pretty
much all happens the way that it's going
to happen in your mind some of the
things about the movie that I liked was
the animation the 3d was fantastic the
3d was definitely really good I wouldn't
say you have to see this movie in 3d but
it did look very great there were a lot
of shots particularly one where the
snail was like on a highway and the rain
was hitting the street the voice I think
is pretty good although I could tell was
Ryan Reynolds the whole time which was a
little distracting because he wasn't
really changing his voice
doing anything special it was just Ryan
Reynolds voice so it did kind of
distract me a little bit but he didn't
do a bad job Paul Giamatti as his
brother I really liked him Samuel
Jackson came in as this kind of cool
other snail who was into racing and
everything turbo runs into this taco
salesman who runs a stand with his
brother and through those two brothers
and then turbo and his brother you kind
of see a mirror image of the two and
they relate to each other in various
ways so there were definitely things in
the movie that we're enjoyable and story
elements that would be good for kids but
it's just so predictable and you know
where everything is going so all in all
I don't think turbos a movie that you
need to rush out and see I think if you
were forced to watch it you wouldn't
mind it but it's not really worth your
time I don't really think I think you
can probably pass on turbo and still
enjoy your weekend I would say go see
the conjuring yeah I'm gonna give turbo
a c-plus kids will enjoy it adults won't
mind it maybe so I like to know have you
guys seen turbo and what did you think
of it if you have as always guys thanks
a lot for watching and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
man eyes
[Music]